hallo zusammen guten Abend wir melden
uns mit ZDF heute live die Ukraine
braucht Flugabwehr sie braucht
Kampfpanzer und sie braucht Munition und
das sogar sehr sehr dringend wie groß
der Mangel ist wie viel Nachschub aus
Europa kommen könnte und welche
Auswirkungen das auf den Kriegsverlauf
hat das wollen wir uns heute anschauen
schickt uns eure Fragen und eure
Kommentare die schreibt am besten
einfach in die Chats rein oder ihr
schreibt sie eine E-Mail-Adresse die
jetzt eingeblendet wird wir sprechen
gleich mit dem militär-experten
Christian möhling von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik und
wir schauen aber vorher direkt in die
Ukraine wir schalten zu unserem
reporterhändler heberstreit er ist
gerade in niebrook hallo Hanna
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend wir sprechen gleich aber
vorher ganz kurz ein paar Zahlen damit
diese Dimension noch mal deutlich wird
Russlands Angreifer wie auch die
ukrainischen Verteidiger beide Seiten
verschießen große Mengen an Munition
mittlerweile wirkt sich der hohe
Verbrauch auf beiden Seiten aus mit
entscheidend für den Verlauf des Krieges
ist der Nachschub denn der Ukraine droht
Munitionsknappheit ein Dokument des
estnischen
Verteidigungsministeriums liefert nun
einen Denkanstoß für die EU darin drei
Zahlen drei alarmierende Warnungen dem
Papier zufolge verschießt Russland pro
Tag 20.000 bis 60.000 Artillerie
Geschosse die Ukraine muss sparen
verbraucht im Vergleich zu Russland nur
etwa ein Zehntel pro Tag zwischen 200
und 7000 Geschosse und Europa die
europäische Rüstungsindustrie produziert
aktuell gerade mal 20.000 bis 25000
Geschosse allerdings pro Monat damit
verschießt Russland an einem einzigen
Tag bis zu drei Mal so viel Munition wie
die europäische Rüstungsindustrie
monatlich produziert
genau das sind eindrückliche zahlen aber
du bist vor Ort du sprichst mit den
Leuten was hörst du geht die Munition
aus
richtig ausgeht weiß ich nicht aber es
herrscht wohl tatsächlich großer Mangel
wir haben von dem Kommandeur eines
Bataillons eines das nennt sich Swoboda
haben wir ein paar Zahlen bekommen und
der sagt zum Beispiel dass man im Herbst
noch etwa 100 mehrfach Raketen aus dem
entsprechenden Raketenwerfer hat
abfeuern können heute sind es am Tag nur
noch 10 das ist also wirklich ein
erheblicher Rückgang an Feuerkraft die
man alleine auf dem Sektor hat dann geht
es auch um leichtere Artillerie Granaten
und und und und kleine Raketenwerfer
also all diese Granaten die der infanti
wir wollen vorrücken helfen da mangelt
ist dran und das ist natürlich für die
Kämpfer am Boden eine sehr gefährliche
Situation und was wir auch gehört haben
dass Distanz Waffen fehlen also
Artillerie Geschosse die tatsächlich auf
größere Distanz
die Angreifer abhalten können und man
nicht immer in den Nahkampf gehen muss
das scheint das zu sein was sie hier
auch sehr stark vermissen
spontane Reaktion von Andreas Scheel auf
Facebook der schreibt ähm dann brauchen
die Panzer doch auch gar nicht erst
geliefert werden wenn keine
Kommunikation da ist
wir reden jetzt hier von von Granaten
für für für Granatwerfer für Artillerie
und dergleichen mehr die Panzer die
sollen ja nun hoffentlich mit ihren
eigenen Equipment hier herankommen das
heißt sowohl Ersatzteile als auch die
entsprechende Munition sonst hat der
Kollege recht
dann ist das ziemlich sinnlos und du
hast mit einem Kommandeur eines
ukrainischen
Spezialkommandos sprechen können das
schauen wir uns an Dein Beitrag
der verrät uns nur seinen Kampfnamen
Commander Kurt rast durch verlassene
Dörfer es sind Randbezirke der Schlacht
um bachmut eine lebensfeindliche
Schlammwüste rundherum wird täglich
geschossen
unsere Aufgabe ist es die Russen maximal
zu entkräften und das klappt wir
beobachten dass ihnen die Kräfte
ausgehen und dass sie gerade nicht in
der Lage sind anderswo große Angriffe zu
starten
in den Ruinen hat kurz sein ukrainisches
Spezialkommando gut versteckt sie planen
so hören wir einen Hinterhalt gegen
russische Einheiten
zu seinen Leuten gehört auch seinen
Vater Nicola
ein Commander ist ein Commander aber ein
Vater ist ein Vater zu Hause bin ich der
Vater hier ist der mein Kommandeur
dann unter Bericht der Lärm des
vorrückenden Panzers den Vater Sohn
Dialog
fährt weiter will so dich dran an der
kontaktlinie zu den Russen lieber in
Bewegung bleiben unterwegs zeigte uns
den Vorrat seine Einheit an Kriegsgerät
das schwierigste ist dass wir jeden Tag
die besten Leute in diesem Krieg
verlieren den die Ukraine nicht
angefangen hat alles andere kann
überwunden werden wenn wir Kameraden
verlieren treibt uns das voran wir haben
ein Ziel wozu ist denn jemand gestorben
wenn wir nicht gewinnen deshalb müssen
wir gewinnen
und so bereiten Sie sich vor auf ihrem
nächsten Einsatz angefroren bei bachmut
Henna du kommst sehr nah an die Menschen
ran die Vertrauen dir und erzählen über
ihre Situation was sagen die welcher
Auswirkungen hat dieser Mangel an
Munition wie zum Beispiel dieses
Kommando damit um was brauchen die
die haben das ist so eine Spezialeinheit
die auch mit Drohnen operiert wir haben
ja den Beitrag gesehen die haben da
Keller voller Kisten gehabt da war
sicherlich einiges von dem Zeug drin was
sie dringend brauchen
diese Truppen sind wahrscheinlich gut
ausgestattet es ist aber insgesamt
Mangel schon festzustellen und der
ergänzt den Mangel auch an Konditionen
den wir von vielen hier gespiegelt
bekommen viele sind müde nach einem Jahr
Krieg sind weit der Heimat entfernt
eingesetzt worden wir haben mit
Kommandos gesprochen die aus der
Westukraine kommen die sind über einem
Jahr die Familie nicht mehr gesehen
haben die laufen im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes offen Zahnfleisch und da ist die
fehlende Munition da noch das
I-Tüpfelchen
was ihre Situation verschlechtert ein
anderes Thema was die Situation dann
auch nicht unbedingt leichter macht ist
das halt auch eben Ersatzteile fehlen
ja wir haben das gesehen wir haben in
einer improvisierten Werkstatt drehen
können wo sie Panzer repariert haben da
erleben wir so oft sonst haben sie auch
erzählt dass sie aus zwei oder drei
Fahrzeugen dann dann dann am Ende eines
machen sie schlachten die Teile aus
teilweise auch erbeutete russische
Panzer es ist ja so dass man oft in
beiden Armeen ähnliche Fahrzeuge
verwendet und da sind sie inzwischen
sehr Entschuldigung inzwischen sehr
geschickt dran ähm im Umgang mit diesen
Sachen wir haben mit einem einem eine
Monteur gesprochen er sagte na ja ich
habe das eine Woche lang gelernt und
jetzt muss ich wohl oder übel wissen wie
das geht das ist wohl jetzt keine
Feinmechanik sieht auseinander und
wieder zusammengesetzt wird aber ja sie
improvisieren und das machen sie ich sag
mal not macht erfinderisch auch ganz gut
aber natürlich Ersatzteile fehlen klar
wir danken dir dass du dir dass du uns
die Situation vor Ort geschildert hast
hier in deinem Team wie immer alles Gute
danke dir tschüss
und wir sprechen jetzt mit dem
militär-experten Christian Mölling von
der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik weiter vorher noch
einen Blick nach Stockholm wo die EU
Verteidigungsminister sich heute mit dem
Thema beschäftigt haben und überlegt
haben wie man denn gemeinsam
unterstützen kann
es ist ein Duo das heute in Stockholm
den Ton sitzt links der
Verteidigungsminister aus der Ukraine
rechts sein größter Fürsprecher aus der
EU der Minister aus Estland beide
verlangen deutlich mehr Hilfe für die
ukrainische Armee als bisher versprochen
Notiz nicht genug wir brauchen eine
Millionen teneriegeschosse das wird 4
Milliarden Euro kosten
wir brauchen Geld und wir brauchen es
schnell
der ukrainischen Armee geht die Munition
aus und Russland verschießt pro Tag 10
mal so viele Geschosse Europa will
diesen Nachteil ausgleichen doch stellt
statt der geforderten vier erst einmal
nur eine Milliarde Euro in Aussicht
nun das Geld fällt nicht vom Himmel wir
haben die Ressourcen die wir haben und
die sollten wir zunächst nutzen
heute einigen sich die
eu-verteidigungsminister im Grundsatz
künftig will Europa gemeinsam Munition
Einkaufen so wie man zuletzt gemeinsam
Corona Impfstoffe gekauft hatte doch wie
damals gibt es einen Engpass nicht in
erster Linie Geld
und die Produktion gerade wenn die
Produktion jetzt hochgefahren werden
könnte was sie nicht unmittelbar kann
dann würde sofort auch bestellt bzw
abgenommen werden können Ende des Monats
könnten erst der Aufträge an die
Industrie gehen und bis dahin wird aus
den eigenen Lagerbeständen geliefert was
Europa noch entbehren kann
guten Abend Herr Müller
leider können wir sie momentan nicht
hören
ich probiere
ich probiere es nochmal hallo ja jetzt
hören wir sie wunderbar einmal der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borrell den wir eben
auch in den Beitrag gesehen haben der
hat kürzlich gesagt wenn die EU in
dieser Frage versagen würde dann sei das
Ergebnis des Krieges in Gefahr da stellt
man sich die Frage warum jetzt also der
Krieg dauert ja immerhin schon über ein
Jahr
ja fast schon ein bisschen zynisch dass
die Europäische Union glaubt nach einem
Jahr tatsächlich den entscheidenden
Unterschied zu machen
in der Tat haben wir schon viele
EU-Staaten die gleichzeitig nach Staaten
sind sehr wohl schon reagiert ähm
gleichzeitig muss man sagen alles was an
Hilfe noch geliefert werden kann ist
natürlich willkommen ähm das bedeutet
aber vor allen Dingen dass die
Europäische Union schnell Geld zur
Verfügung stellen muss und nicht einen
Beschaffungsprozess organisieren sollte
unter dem alle 27 Staaten dann doch
wieder mit zu reden haben und versuchen
ihre eigene Rüstungsindustrie wieder
nach vorne
und wenn man das jetzt hört eine
Milliarde in Aussicht gestellt kann das
funktionieren reicht das aus kann die
Rüstungsindustrie überhaupt liefern
also die Industrie nach Aussagen der
Industrie kann liefern das Geld reicht
nicht und es ist noch nicht da ich
glaube so einfach ist es das heißt es
ist wunderbar dass man sich trifft dass
man in Brüssel darüber spricht und auch
in stock und darüber spricht aber das
Geld schießt nicht die Munition wird
verschossen das heißt also hier muss
tatsächlich deutlich mehr
Geschwindigkeit auf den
auf die auf die Kette kommen ansonsten
hat die Europäische Union wenn Sie es
sind selber sozusagen schon als als
Messlatte hinlegt versagt die
Europäische Union ein weiteres Mal bei
einer großen geopolitischen
Herausforderung
jetzt hat er
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius eben in
den Beitrag gesagt dass aber der der
Engpass die Produktion sei wiefern
der Widerspruch ist möglicherweise eine
Informationen die da sind oder aber mit
Blick auf die Frage für wen eigentlich
produziert wird das heißt also wir haben
große Produktionskapazitäten nicht nur
in Deutschland in Europa sondern auch
weltweit von Unternehmen die in
Deutschland in Europa tätig sind die
Frage ist wie kommt man jetzt an die
Munition die da produziert wird dran und
wie wie kriegt man das Zeitner hin ich
bin mir ganz sicher dass der
Verteidigungsminister mit den
Produzenten im Gespräch ist das
wichtigste ist das hier einfach nicht zu
viele Köche jetzt mit reinkommen sondern
dass man der Industrie erstens klar sagt
dass Geld kommt und am besten der
Ukraine das Geld gibt damit die das
bestellt was sie braucht in der Menge
und in der Qualität die sie braucht
dafür braucht es keine Brüste Bürokratie
die Bürokratie kann und sollte das Geld
so schnell wie möglich zur Verfügung
stellen
eben auch gehört dass die EU so eine Art
Sammelbestellung machen will wie damals
bei dem Corona Impfstoffen und damals
bei den Corona Impfstoffen war ja unter
anderem auch das Ziel einer großen
Bestellung günstigere Preise zu
erreichen
ist das das richtige Signal an die
Rüstungsindustrie
nein das richtige Signal ist wir kaufen
so schnell wie möglich alles was geht
denn der Preis den man hier zahlt der
ökonomische Preis steht nicht oder steht
in einem sehr ungleichen Verhältnis zum
zum politischen Preis den man jetzt
zahlen würde wir haben schon so viel
investiert in diese ganze Geschichte
dass man jetzt anfängt sich zu überlegen
man könnte hier noch Skalen Effekte
ausnutzen wenn man den Prozess dafür
aber zeitlich in die Länge ziehen würde
denn das müsste dann ja wiederum
passieren halte ich für eine für eine
wirklich sehr unglückliche Geschichte
was man von mir aus gerne machen kann
ist sagen wir fangen erstmal an mit
einer großen Bestellung aber die Ukraine
soll bestellen nicht die Europäische
Union bestellt sondern die Ukraine die
weiß was sie braucht dass die
Europäische Union sich jetzt Gedanken
darüber macht was die Europäer was die
Ukraine brauchen könnte das ist total
nett hilft aber in der jetzigen
Situation überhaupt
und vor allem klingt das alles danach
als ob es noch sehr sehr lange dauern
kann und bis es dann soweit ist dann
sollen die einzelnen Staaten ja jetzt
weiter aus ihrem Lagerbeständen
aushelfen
wie weit kommt die Ukraine damit
das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen aber klar
ist dass die europäischen Staaten nicht
nur Deutschland sondern auch andere
offensichtlich des NATO Ziel nicht
erreicht haben nämlich 30 Tage
vorzuhalten wir können nur drei Tage
vorhalten das sind dann zehn Prozent des
ganzen wir alle anderen so da stehen
dann ist es ziemlich schwach
das ist aber jetzt auch im Grunde
genommen vergossene Milch wir sind jetzt
in der Situation wo wir auch nur
getriggert durch die Situation vor Ort
tatsächlich über die Dramatik sprechen
klar war dieser Munitionsmangel im
Grunde schon seit Monaten wir wussten
seit Monaten weil es eigentlich eine
relativ einfache dreisatzrechnung ist
wie viel Munition verschossen wird wie
viel verfügbar ist und wann dann neue
gebraucht wird hätte man schon längst
handeln können mit vorausschauenden
Handel und planen vor allem Handeln hat
das hier zurzeit nichts zu tun das ist
irgendwie nur getriggert dadurch dass
jetzt eine öffentliche Diskussion geht
und der Ukraine die Munition droht
tatsächlich auszugehen das heißt man
handelt wiederum auf den letzten Drücker
lassen Sie uns mal schauen was im Chat
los ist da stellt man sich die Frage ob
das so sinnvoll ist das öffentlich zu
diskutieren also Stefan schreibt auf
Youtube was bezweckt man damit den
Gegner über die eigenen
munitionskapazitäten zu informieren oder
Caterpillar schreibt ist das günstig den
mangelnden Munitionsvorrat des Westens
und damit der Ukraine in der
Öffentlichkeit zu diskutieren der Feind
würde er mithören
ja das ist ein offenes Geheimnis also
dass wir nicht ausreichend Munition
haben war lange vor dem Ukraine Konflikt
klar auch das ist sozusagen dann das
traurige dass wir eben genommen für
Deutschland spätestens seit 2019 klare
Zahlen dafür hatten was ein Munition
fehlt und wir seitdem nicht bestellt
haben und jetzt stehen wir im Grunde vor
dem Scherbenhaufen aber zurück zu der
Frage kann man das diskutieren wir
diskutieren ja keine einzelzahlen das
würde ich auch nicht tun also da gibt's
sozusagen die Fragen operativer
Sicherheit wo das
Verteidigungsministerium und andere
keine Zahlen zur Verfügung stellen
würden und wir Sie auch eine
Öffentlichkeit nicht diskutieren würden
selbst wenn wir sie hätten von daher
können wir sozusagen sagen es ist ein
Problem da das ist auch offensichtlich
das ist da ist und ein Teil der Zahlen
die jetzt sehr abstrakt in die
Öffentlichkeit gestellt worden sind
die braucht man glaube ich schon um die
Dramatik klar zu machen
die sind aber nichts voraus Russland zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt Rückschlüsse ziehen
könnte die es selber nicht ziehen kann
in Russland zählt ja auch wie viele
Einschläge von Granaten jeden Tag
stattfinden oder kann das zumindest
zählen und so auf dem
durchschnittsmunitionsverbrauch kommt
dazu auch eine Frage wie viel Munition
können denn die Russen produzieren
ja auch da Russland lässt uns natürlich
darüber unklaren was wir was wir sehen
sind immer nur Hinweisen also da muss
man mal sozusagen mit Blick auf die
Realitäten immer eine Schippe runter
nehmen wir sehen die Hinweise dass
Russland versucht offensichtlich
Munition im Ausland zu kaufen
also im Iran die Drohnen der Versuch bei
Nordkorea und möglicherweise auch China
zu versuchen an Munition zu kommen auch
da gibt's Probleme was die Versorgung
mit Munition angeht wie weit das geht
das wage ich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht nicht einzuschätzen darüber gibt
es unterschiedliche Einschätzung die
Einschätzung sagen das ist auch für
Russland schwierig aber sicherlich nicht
zu schwierig für die Ukraine weil die
deutlich stärker von der westlichen
Produktion abhängt als die Urus als
Russland von irgendeiner vergleichbaren
aus Menschen
und dann gibt es noch eine Frage von
TomTom der fragt entwaffnen wir nicht
gerade die EU wenn wir eben diese ganzen
Lagerbestände weitergeben er schreibt
dann könnte doch Putin versucht sein
einfach durch zu marschieren
nein das kann er nicht also erstens hat
Putin ja genau das verloren was er zum
durchmarschieren bräuchte nämlich ein
landstreit macht die russische Armee
insgesamt der russischen russischen
Streitkräfte sind zwar im weitesten Teil
noch intakt aber galt die Armee ist es
nicht und es wären völlig anderer Krieg
der Russland kämpfen müsste ich glaube
da braucht man sich zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt keine Sorgen machen und wir
sehen ja was das dass wir sozusagen
dieser diese kommunizierenden Röhren
also auch der Verteidigungsminister
Ukraine schon seine eigene und das ist
immer das was ich ab gebe habe ich
schnell noch nicht nachgefüllt das dass
wir aber zu Hause nicht nachfüllen
können also bei der Bundeswehr anderen
ist ein Haus gemacht das Problem das ist
kein sozusagen naturgegebenes Gesetz
dass wir das nicht können das hat damit
zu tun dass wir es bislang nicht für
notwendig empfunden haben schnell in
Kriegszeiten nachtragshaushalte zu haben
aus denen heraus für Munition für unsere
eigenen Streitkräfte bekommen können
auch Ersatzteile bekommen können alles
das sind Dinge die wenn man will kann
man das alles hinbekommen aber
offensichtlich ist der Leidensdruck auch
in Deutschland noch nicht groß genug
genommen da würde ich gerne noch mal
nachfragen denn wenn die
rüstungshersteller wie sie sagen er
liefern können und wir ja auch wissen es
gibt jetzt seit einem Jahr gibt es sehr
sehr viel Geld ein Budget dafür wo ist
denn das Problem wo sind die Sackgassen
dieser Kassen liegen da drin dass wir
zwar viel Geld haben wenn wir jetzt von
100 Milliarden reden wir sind aber nicht
dazu da Munition zu bestellen die sind
für bestimmte andere Sachen festgelegt
da macht es im Prinzip auch Sinn
bei dem bei der Munition reden wir jetzt
auch nicht von so wahnsinnig viel Geld
wir haben jetzt eben gehört dass die
Ukraine gesagt haben sie brauchen 4
Milliarden das ist was was man aus
meiner Sicht sogar national
bereitstellen könnte einfach um dieses
Thema kurzfristig vom Tisch zu machen
wir haben es mit einer riesigen
Verkettung von unterschiedlichsten
Vorschriften zu tun und dem bislang
nicht vorhandenen Willen diese
Vorschriften zu kippen und damit den Weg
frei zu machen und die Vorschriften
sagen auch natürlich dass das auf der
anderen Seite Geld da sein muss das ist
auch richtig so aber sich hinzustellen
und zu sagen na ja wir können keine
Munition mehr bestellen weil im Haushalt
kein Geld mehr dafür da ist während in
Europa der größte Landkreis seit dem
zweiten weltkriegt ist wechselweise oder
wahlweise entweder zynisch oder ich kann
es gar nicht mehr beschreiben was das
ist also die Frage ist auf welchen Krieg
auch mit Blick auf die Frage die
gestellt worden ist auf welchen Krieg
wollen wir denn noch warten bevor wir
anfangen uns um die Sicherheit Europas
zu kümmern und wen sehen wir denn außer
Russland zurzeit als seine größte
größere Bedrohung noch an die wir uns
möglicherweise militäre schützen oder
sogar durch Hilfe der Ukraine
verteidigen können
es gibt noch eine weitere Frage
Deutschland will doch mehrere Leopard 1
und 2 von der Schweiz kaufen gibt es da
was konkretes nun ist es ja auch so dass
die Situation mit der Schweiz jetzt
nicht ganz einfach ist was die
Lieferungen angeht an die Ukraine
genau also die
so wie ich das verstanden habe oder mein
letzter Stand ist mit Blick auf diese
Anfragen dass die Firma Rheinmetall
offizielle Anfrage gestellt hat an die
Schweiz an die Schweizer Regierung mit
der Bitte um Prüfung ob das möglich wäre
überhaupt und dann würde man
wahrscheinlich wenn das positiv
beschieden würde in weitere
Verhandlungen gehen wie die Schweiz sich
da zu stellt wird sicherlich interessant
sein denn natürlich ist klar dass ein
Metall diese Sachen kaufen möchte um sie
an die Ukraine weiterzugeben oder
irgendwo anders hin zu verkaufen und die
Schweiz steht damit in einem erheblichen
Spannungsverhältnis zwischen den
geopolitischen Realitäten auf der einen
Seite nämlich einen großen Land Krieg in
Europa und dem
besonderen neutralitätsverständnis dass
man in der Schweiz pflegt und das
bislang nicht unter Druck geraten ist
das heißt den Schweizern geht so ein
bisschen auch wie den deutschen dass man
sich viele ein
eingeölt hat in
wieder Normativität und diese
Normativität jetzt durch die Realität
eines brutalen Krieges herausgefordert
wird
bleiben wir bei der Rüstungsindustrie
wir schauen uns mal an wie viele
Zulieferer zum Beispiel an einem Leopard
2 Panzer beteiligt sind
der Leopard 2 er gilt als einer der
leistungsfähigsten und modernsten
Kampfpanzer der Welt mehrere hundert
Firmen liefern Bauteile für die
Fertigung zu Haupthersteller ist Krauss
Maffay Wegmann das Münchner Unternehmen
baut die Wanne die äußere Hülle des
Panzers und ist für die Montage
verantwortlich weitere Zuliefer sind
etwa MWK Defense in Sachsen sie liefern
die Panzerketten das Getriebe kommt von
der Augsburger Rang Group die
Rolls-Royce Tochter MTU produziert den
Dieselmotor der panzerstall kommt vom
schwedischen Stahlkonzern
die Hauptwaffe die glatt Waffenanlage
steuert das deutsche Rüstungsunternehmen
Rheinmetall bei ebenso die
Feuerleitanlage
das klingt wahnsinnig komplex und macht
das eben die Produktion und die
Genehmigung und die Weitergabe macht das
alles noch viel komplizierter
nicht unbedingt ich glaube man muss sich
das vorstellen dass wir hier ist im
Idealfall zwar mit ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen Teilen zu tun haben
die alle nachher integriert werden
müssen das ist die besondere Leistung
die ausmacher wegmanns dann zustande
bringen müssen aber im Idealfall haben
sie es mit ganz vielen unterschiedlichen
zahlenrädchen zu tun die alle wunderbar
gut ineinander greifen in der Realität
ist es aber nicht so weil wir zum
Beispiel viel zu wenig bestellt haben
das heißt also es fehlen teilweise
Zahnrädchen wenn Sie nur ein oder zwei
Panzer abnehmen pro Jahr oder die auch
vielleicht gar nicht abnehmen dann sagt
irgendwann der Lieferant also hängen ja
hunderte von von Teilen und auch die
Verwandten dahinter sagt dann irgendwann
na ja aber jetzt kann ich dir das Teil
nicht mehr geben das ist schon so alt
oder ich habe es weiterverkauft wenn
jemand anderes das heißt also wir haben
großes Problem dieses Räderwerk was ähm
was passiert sozusagen
zusammengebaut und zusammengehalten
werden muss ständig am laufen werden
muss da ständig am Laufen zu halten weil
wir die Leistung nicht der deutschen
Rüstungsindustrie einfach nicht
regelmäßig Abfrage das tröpfelt im
Grunde genommen da immer nur so raus und
mal kommt auch gar nichts raus
ich habe noch eine Frage aus dem Chat
da schreibt rabbit müssen wir nicht
irgendwann weitere Industrie auf
kriegsproduktionen umstellen ähnlich wie
im Zweiten Weltkrieg da hat ja heute der
eu-bindenmarktkommissar Breton genau das
irgendwie angeregt Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius hat er schon abgelehnt wie es
ihre Haltung
ja ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau was
der Begriff Kriegswirtschaft bedeuten
soll
klar ist wenn wir versuchen sollten
jetzt die Industrie umzustellen
aufzubauen über das was jetzt schon da
ist dann wird das einfach Jahre dauern
ähm das heißt also das ist im Prinzip
schon richtig um eine langfristige
Verteidigungsfähigkeit herzustellen wir
lernen jetzt ja auch gerade das
verteidigungs-, eine
verteidigungsindustrielle Basis und auch
technologische Basis für den Betrieb von
Streitkräften einfach essentiell ist
insbesondere im Krieg aber auch in der
Friedenszeit um sie quasi
innovationsfähig und modern zu halten
aber mit Blick auf den Ukraine Konflikt
kommen alle diese Wünsche jetzt gerade
sehr sehr spät und sie sind das muss man
auch sagen seit Jahren gibt es diese
Ideen theoretische sind aber nie in die
Praxis umgesetzt worden also warum das
dieses Mal passiert wenn man es schon
nicht schafft seit einem Jahr die
Munition auf die Kette zu kriegen
da bin ich jetzt erstmal zurückhaltend
zu glauben dass die Europäische Union
oder auch die einzelnen Staaten da zügig
was in die in die Gänge bringen können
war es aber dass wir ein Wiederaufbau
der Industrie und vor allem ihrer
lackierten logischen Leistungsfähigkeit
auf diesen zehn bis 15 Jahre unbedingt
ins Auge fassen müssen
Sven fragt noch mal nach der
Organisation er fragt gibt es denn eine
zentrale Instanz in der EU die die
Beschaffung jetzt organisiert oder wie
soll das ganz konkret ablaufen
nein es ist sehr unterschiedlich die
Europäische Union hat
zwar die Mühe hätte die Möglichkeit
sowas zu organisieren es gibt auch in
Europa aber nicht nur Europäischen Union
eine Organisation die kann sowas
bestellen man muss sich das aber auch
ganz klar so vorstellen Rüstung und
Verteidigung sind die beiden Bereiche in
denen die europäischen Staaten immer
sehr stark auf ihr Recht gebraucht haben
nationale Souveränität zu haben oder
Eigenständigkeit behalten zu wollen die
Eigenständigkeit der hat in der Realität
war schon lange nicht mehr gegeben weil
man sehr viel stärker von den
Entscheidungen der Partner abhängig
gewesen ist zumindest wenn man Dinge tun
wollte nicht wenn man Dinge nicht tun
wollte aber man hat sich diese Illusion
zumindest immer wieder hingegeben ob man
das jetzt schafft zu überwinden das ist
die große Frage man darf die Hoffnung
sicherlich nicht aufgeben aber ich
glaube man kann sehr realistisch sagen
dass die Europäische Union dafür
tatsächlich und die starken Europäischen
Union und Deutschland und Frankreich
gehören zu den Wesen wir starten hier
tatsächlich stark auf ihre
ihr eigenes Verhalten verändern müssten
um tatsächlich hier einen solchen
Quantensprung zu machen und eine
europäische Beschaffung
initiieren zu können nochmal kurz eine
Frage zu den Kampfpanzern jetzt hat rein
Metall angekündigt dass die Firma gerne
eine Panzerfabrik mitten in der Ukraine
bauen würde und da den Typ Panther gerne
produzieren würde dann damit wäre die
Ukraine glaube ich das erste Land den
das überhaupt nutzen würde wie
realistisch ist das und könnte das
funktionieren
also das Rheinmetall in der Ukraine eine
Panzerfabrik aufbaut halte ich für sehr
realistisch die Ukraine hat Erfahrung
das heißt es gibt Menschen theoretischen
Ukraine die wahrscheinlich das Skillset
die Fähigkeiten haben
so etwas zu bearbeiten
ich würde mich an dem Namen Panther oder
der Idee des Kampfpanzer dahinter steht
jetzt glaube ich erstmal gar nicht so
aufhängen ähm das ist glaube ich eher
eine Marketing Geschichte des
Unternehmens wo man versucht dann Namen
ins Rennen zu bringen und auch den
sowohl die mit Kandidaten ein bisschen
Angst zu machen als auch den Aktionären
große Hoffnung zu geben dass es gut ist
bei der Firma weiterhin Aktien zu kaufen
das gehört zum zum Handwerk mit dazu ähm
aber klar warum soll rein Metall nicht
versuchen gerade wenn die Ukraine auf
lange aufgerüstet werden muss denn das
steckt ja dahinter steckt nichts
Interesse dahinter in Deutschland haben
warum soll man da nicht jetzt schon
anfangen darüber nachzudenken solche
Strukturen
noch mal zwei Kommentare aus dem Chat da
schreibt Schock Flyer one eine Waffen
schaffen in diesem Fall Frieden und the
critical schreibt genau das Gegenteil
frieden kann man nur schaffen ohne
Waffen also wenn die Ukraine denken das
vielleicht mal durch ab morgen jetzt
keine Waffenlieferungen mehr bekommen
würde würde das Frieden schaffen
ja das hängt glaube ich dann von der
Definition des Friedens ab also
irgendwann bestimmt dann einfach
Russland was dann Frieden ist
bringt die Leute um die es nicht mehr
haben möchte wenn Frieden bedeutet dass
die Leute dann nicht mehr sterben dann
ist die Konzeption von Frieden oder dann
ist wird das damit nicht erreicht denn
wir sehen ja das gerade in den Gebieten
die Russisch besetzt gewesen sind und
die nachher zurückgenommen worden sind
von der ukrainischen Armee dass sie voll
mit Folterkellern mit toten Menschen
sind mit Augenzeugen berichten die die
unveröffentlicht hat von Vergewaltigung
von Vertreibung von Verschleppung von
Kindern also wenn das der Frieden ist in
einige in diesem Land haben möchten dann
kann ich das auch eine gewisse Art und
Weise schon verstehen dass man seine
Ruhe haben möchte aber auch diese Ruhe
ist trügerisch es gibt keinen Grund zu
glauben das ist Putin in diesem Konflikt
um um die Ukraine alleine geht sondern
es geht darum dass insbesondere die
Europäische Union und ihre Staaten aus
seiner Sicht fast sind
und jetzt können wir noch mal auf unsere
Eingangsfrage zurück zum Schluss dieser
Mangel an Ressourcen an Munition
inwiefern verlängert das Ding
naja letztendlich geht es im Krieg nicht
um Zeit sondern es geht um die
Möglichkeit tatsächlich eine eine
Entscheidung herbeizuführen und das hat
was mit mit Intensität zu tun ich will
das mal versuchen ganz praktisch zu
machen Russland kann natürlich auf dem
sehr niedrigen Aktivitätsniveau wie ist
das zurzeit macht diesen Krieg sehr
lange noch durchhalten deswegen ist es
der Versuch der Ukraine in die Offensive
zu kommen und mit Geschwindigkeit und
Feuerkraft tatsächlich hier die
Schwächen der russischen Armee ähm zum
Vorschein zu bringen und damit auch ein
militärischen Vorteil für die Ukraine zu
erschaffen und damit letztendlich auch
eine bessere Ausgangsposition für
entweder Verhandlung oder für einen
Stillstand dieses Krieges ich würde gar
nicht von einfrieren sprechen dieser
Konflikt wird wahrscheinlich nicht
einfrieren sondern er wird irgendwann
einmal quasi zu einem militärischen
Stillstand kommen an dem sich beide
Seiten weiterhin bedrohen werden und das
Maß der Bedrohung dass man gegeneinander
aufbauen kann das bestimmt wie stabil
dieser dennoch fragile kann man gar
nicht sagen das Schweigen der Waffen
sein wird
und wie ist ihre Prognose wie werden die
nächsten Monate weitergehen
ja wir sind in diesem Jahr im
entscheidenden Jahr des Krieges und wir
stehen vor der Frage schafft die Ukraine
ist eine große Frühjahrsoffensive
tatsächlich
bald zu starten dafür wären halt die
Kampfpanzer eine große Hilfe
weil es einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit
steigert dass das ähm die Ukraine
erfolgreich ist
und damit auch ein entscheidenden
Schritt in in Richtung Eroberung ihre
eigene Gebiete tatsächlich machen kann
das wäre schon insofern auch ein
entscheidender Schritt für dieses Jahr
weil damit klar ist dass Russland ein
weiteres Jahr nicht in der Lage gewesen
sein wird seine Kriegsziele zu erreichen
und sich damit überlegen muss wie will
es denn jetzt eigentlich weitermachen
tatsächlich aber dazu gehört eben das
wichtige Zeichen an die politische
Führung in Moskau dass es eben nicht
möglich ist seine militärischen
Interessen seine politischen Interessen
mit militärischer Gewalt
gegen die Ukraine und gegen den Rest
Europas durchzusetzen
wir danken Ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie
uns das alles auseinandergedröselt haben
und
uns eingeordnet haben vielen Dank
schönen Abend noch sehr gerne schönen
Abend tschüss an alle Ciao ja und damit
verabschieden wir uns dann wünschen
ebenfalls noch einen schönen Abend und
sagen bis bald tschüss